from the early hours the international
press had gathered waiting for an update
from this historic meeting eventually it
came as a personal message from Her
Majesty the Queen said today my family
had very constructive discussions on the
future of my grandson and his family my
family and I are entirely supportive of
Harry and Megan's desire to create a new
life as a young family although we would
have preferred them to remain full-time
working members of the royal family we
respect and understand their wish to
live a more independent life as a family
while remaining a valued part of my
family
Harry and Megan have made clear that
they do not want to be reliant on public
funds in their new lives it has
therefore been agreed that there will be
a period of transition in which the
Sussex is will spend time in Canada and
the UK these are complex matters for my
family to resolve and there is some more
work to be done but I have asked for
final decisions to be reached in the
coming days it has been an extraordinary
week since Harry and Megan broke ranks
on Wednesday announcing they want to
step back as senior Royals today's
meeting was meant to be a public display
that they are now working together it
was highly unusual the Queen would even
want us to know that this family meeting
was taking place but it's unlikely we'll
get any definitive answers on the next
steps until all members of the family
are fully in agreement on what should be
done for Harry and Megan the reputation
or damage for the family and the
institution has already been too much
since the announcement that blame game
has started as to who or what led them
to make this move the rift between the
two brothers has been part of the
speculation but today they came out
together denying reports that Prince
William had pushed Prince Harry and
Megan away with his bullying attitude a
reminder that at the centre of this are
fragile relationships I think they're
they're very close you know obviously
they lost their mother at a young age
and you know had to be supportive of
each other throughout obviously now you
know William's with Kate he's got his
own family now Harry's got his own so
didn't actually they're going to be set
rainbow I don't think is as bad as what
the press are making up the newcomer to
the family was expected to dial into the
meeting from Canada Megan in the past
has talked about struggling to adjust
her new life especially the media
scrutiny there's never gonna be the case
that this is going to be that she was
going to be accepted warming into the
royal family or the public perception of
the royal family I think the biggest
surprise from the press has been that it
has been really the right-wing press
that's chased the couple out of public
life and now that they've run away from
the royal family there they're even
piling on even more they seems to be a
case of you really can't win whatever
you do the informal tone of the Queen's
statement is telling speaking as a
grandmother as well as the head of this
institution she makes it clear they
don't have all the answers yet but they
will remain united behind one of their
own Rhiannon Mills Sky News in
Sandringham